صراع النجم الثالثه بين الرقصه الاخيره
وبلال جديد يعني هي بالحرف تلخيص لنهائي
كاس العالم 2022 في قطر اللي ما راح يكون
نهائي عادي هو نهائي تاريخي لكل المقايس
لانه راح يشهد اخر مباراه في كاس العالم
لاحد افضل اللاعبين في تاريخ كره القدم
على الاطلاق وليونيل ميسي وربما ولاده نجم
جديد يقترب من انجاز بيليه ويحققه مره
اخرى وهو طبعا بالتاكيد كيليان مبابي وليش
عم نقارن بليه لانه بيليه هو كان اخر لاعب
حقق لقب كاس العالم في نسختين متتاليتين
1958 1962 وامبابي اذا ما حقق اللقب بيوم
الاحد راح يكون ثاني لاعب كبير طبعا بارز
بالتاريخ يحقق هذا الانجاز
وبالتالي من الان كان نسال الناس بالشارع
عن مبابي كثير من الناس شبهوه بليه
ورؤوا انه ممكن يعيد تحقيق الانجاز الي
حققه بليه بال 1962 بتشيلي طيب خلينا
ننتقل للحديث عن المباراه
المباراه بين الارجنتين وفرنسا مباراه
طبعا مثلنا نعرف هي مباراه معقده مباراه
صعبه مباراه فيها تفاصيل كثير تفاصيل
تكتيكيه كثير ولكن اذا بدنا نحكي شويه
بشويه تكتيك بدون ما نفوت بالتفاصيل كثير
الارجنتين لعبه بطريقتين بهذه البطوله
ثلاثه خمسه اثنين خمسه ثلاثه اثنين سميها
ما شئت كل واحد بيحب يسميها على كيفه
ولكن كانت دائما ناجحه بطريقه ال 442 اكثر
من طريقه ال 352 او 352 ولكن رقم ذلك لعبت
بهذه الطريقه امام هولندا ونجحت متعدده
الدور الثاني يعني بركلات الترجيح
امام فرنسا رغم انه يبدو على الورق من
الاربع اربعه اثنين ممكن تكون افضل
للمنتخب الارجنتيني ولكن بالنظر لامكانيات
المنتخب الفرنسي ربما خطه
الدفاعيه اكثر شوي هي الانسب للمنتخب
الارجنتيني وليش هون في سبب لانه لما انت
يكون عندك مثلا اذا لعبه شوميني اللي هو
مصاب ولكن اذا لعب او اي لاعب اخر راح
يلعب بداله مع جريزمان ورابيو بنصف الملعب
هذول ثلاث لاعبين المنتخب الفرنسي مقابل
ثلاثه لاعبين ايضا للمنتخب الارجنتيني
هنريديس ديبول
وانجو فاندس لما تلعب بهذه الطريقه تقدر
تسمح لميسي ايضا انه ينزل يعمل اوفر دوت
بنص الملعب
مقابل ثلاثه للمنتخب الفرنسي وهذا تفوق
عدل واي تفوق عددي مع ميسي ايضا للمنتخب
الارجنتيني ممكن يكون اخطر على المرمى
الفرنسي ويملك نص الملعب هون راح تحط
للمنتخب الفرنسي بيورطه
لان المدافع الايسر للمنتخب الفرنسي ان
كان قناتي اوباميكانو او ايا كان راح يضطر
انه يرجع مع ميسي او يدخل مع ميسي بيعمق
الملعب مثل ما صار بمباراه هولندا لما سحب
ميسي نيوتن اكى وفتح المجله مولينا انه
يدخل داخل منطقه الجزاء ويسجل هدف وهو
بالضبط ما يمكن ان يحدث مع المنتخب
الفرنسي اذا مسي عمل الاوفرلود بنص الملعب
راح يضطر يسحب معه مدافع من فرنسا
وبالتالي هيفتح المساحه لامولينا على
الجهه اليمنى او لا اكون على الجهه اليسرى
على اي جهه كان موجود عم بيلعب راح يكون
عم بيفتح مساحه للظهير تبع الارجنتين
النقطه الاخرى المميزه بهذه الخطه انه انت
فعاليه لما بتكون عم بتافه او لما بتكون
الكره معك ومستحوض عليها واغلب الظن
الارجنتين هي راح تكون اكثر استحواذان على
الكره عندك خطوره الجهه اليسرى عن طريق
كيليان مبابي كيليان مبابي اذا اظهرتك
متقدمين الى الامام راح يكون بموقف الواحد
على واحد مع مدافع المنتخب الارجنتين اللي
وراء نعم ممكن يكون في مساعده بنص الملعب
بس احنا بنعرف انه حتى لاعبين على بابي
الامور ممكن تكون صعبه لما يكون عنده
مساحه مثل ما شفنا مع المنتخب المغربي
لذلك المنتخب الارجنتيني بهذه الطريقه
بيقدر يحمي دفعه بشكل كثير منيح انه بيكون
عنده رومير وقراءه سنتر باك وراء اوتمندي
حاميه بالاضافه للمساند الدفاعيه من ديبول
على مبابي بالمرتدات الامور بتكون جيده
جدا
رئيسيتين الان بالنسبه لحال الهجوميه فقوه
المنتخب الفرنسي هجوميا هي بكليان مبابي
ولكن نقطه ضعف دفاعيا هي ايضا بابل هو
لاعب الوحيد بالمنتخب الفرنسي اللي ما
بيضغط واللاعب الوحيد اللي ما بيرجع
دفاعيا هو بس مهمته الدفاعيه او ضمن
المنظومه الدفاعيه انه بيغلق زاويه
التمرير بين المدافع الايمن وبين الرايت
باك اللي هو بيكون الظهير الايمن
وبالتالي نشوف بمباراه المغرب وفرنسا ان
المغرب خلال شوط المباراه الاول والثاني
كان تركيزه الاساسي على الجهه اليسرى
للمنتخب الفرنسي الجهه اليمنى للمنتخب
المغربي لايجاد حكيمي وزياش وهو الامر
المتوقع في مباراه الارجنتين لانه فرنسا
بصراحه ما عنده حل على هذه الجهه راح يكون
منتخب الارجنتين بكثير محلات بموقفه ثلاثه
على واحد على
ميسي
الاهم هجوميه بالنسبه للمنتخب الارجنتيني
والفكره الاهم اللي لازم يلعب عليها
المنتخب الارجنتيني بهذه المباراه
بالمقابل المنتخب الطبيعيه
[موسيقى]
انت حدثنا عن قريبوس عندي بول عن انزو
فرنانديز اللي هو اسرع لاعب فيهم ولكن رغم
ذلك وبطيء ان تحدثنا عن اي لاعب حتى ما
كالتر بالنسبه للمنتخب الارجنتيني هذول
اللاعبين بطيئين ما عندهم قدره انهم
يجاروا او جريزمان او روبيو بالحاله جميله
لمنتخب فرنسا وبالتالي فرنسا اكيد راح
تعتمد على المرتدات وعلى سرعه لاعبين وسط
بنقل الكره من ثلث الى اخر وتحديدا هنا عم
نحكي عن جريزمان اللي راح يلعب دور مهم
جدا بيقطع الكرات من المنتخب الارجنتيني
بمنطقه نص الملعب ونقلها للثلث الامامي
على طول باتجاه الكليان مبابي او عثمان
ديمبلي طبعا براي شخص او كتوقع الارجنتين
هي الاقرب لتحقيق لقب لانه بكل امانه وبكل
صراحه المنتخب الارجنتيني كل المؤشرات عم
بتشير على انه هو المنتخب المرشح لتحقيق
اللقب هناك في حالات مرضيه وانفلونزا
منتشره عند المنتخب الفرنسي
خسرنا شايفين انه في ثلاثه لاعبين تقريبا
اصيبوا بانفلونزا ولاعبين غايبين بسبب
الاصابه مع ضمن من قلب الدفاع وبالتالي
الامور صعبه راح تكون على المنتخب الفرنسي
حتى لو لحق هؤلاء اللاعبين بالمباراه لانه
طبعا ما دربوا التدريبات الجماعيه ان كان
الجمعه ما بعرف اذا اليوم راح يتدربوا ولا
لا ولكن اعتقد انه لا توقع الشخصي الى
الارجنتين بطله العالم وميسي يرقص رقصه
الاخيره